mice informatics research conference a
special tuesday edition as often happens
at the end of academic terms we
have a number of additional
presentations of students either
um defending proposals or theses or
dissertations
and so we have a um
master's thesis proposal defense
today um by sarah florig
and sarah is a student in our master of
science and health and clinical
informatics
major um i've actually known her since
before she joined our program because
she
got her first exposure to informatics in
a course that ted ladaris and i
uh taught at portland state
undergraduate a number of years ago
and hopefully that kindled her
enthusiasm and she did enroll in our
program
after she had received her uh bachelor
of science degrees from portland state
in health studies and in general science
in addition to being a master's student
she currently works as a research
assistant in pulmonary and critical
medicine with dr jeff gold
who's on her committee their
investigation center around
ehr usability ehr training through
simulated patient charts and how the ehr
influences interprofessional team
dynamics
her research interests include the
impact of ehrs on the quality and safety
of patient care
and connections to clinical behavior and
a secondary topic of enthusiasm for her
is
in the reuse of vhr data for research
purposes
so she's defending her master's thesis
proposal
today and if she does that successfully
and completes her thesis successfully we
will hear back from her in the future
when she comes to actually defend her
thesis so go ahead sarah
alright thank you
sorry just trying to get my content
straight
um okay there we go
there we go and can everyone see
the slides here yes looks great yes it
looks great
all right wonderful
thanks for everyone who made it today
i'm excited
to tell you more about my project to
start off
i just wanted to ask you all to think
about the last time
you went in to see your clinician not
when you opened my chart
um and went into a virtual visit but
actually went down
to your office and sat in the exam room
to see your clinician
and i know it's been a while but i want
you to think about who you interacted
with when you went in
and just how many people used a computer
in the medical office it would not
surprise me at all
if your clinician was one of those
people
in my experience at least they're
usually typing away madly
while we're having our visit to
be able to get ahead of some of the
charting
since adopting electronic health records
study after study has confirmed that
clinicians are spending more and more
time on their computers
not only that but experts agree that
the effort to comply with the complex
regulatory requirements
burdensome documentation rules and the
consuming demands
of suboptimal tech are at the root of
professional burnout to refocus
clinicians on activities that truly
require their training
many organizations have begun to use
medical scribes to reduce the amount of
time clinicians are spending in the ehr
these assistants take real-time notes
for the clinician
uh while they're interacting with the
patient and then after the scribe
completes their note they forward it
to the provider who will go on to add
the
clinically relevant details that someone
who's unlicensed can't
describes then kind of improve the
clinician's workflow
by decreasing their clerical burden and
many studies have previously found that
they're received really well by
patients and providers
while this is a popularized approach to
coping with high workloads
the measurable impacts that scribes have
on documentation
is really challenging to gauge present
ehr capabilities
don't really have or support the use of
real-time analytic tools
to assess clinical documentation
behaviors
and the majority of previous studies
that use
that look at documentation completion
time with scribes
use self-report measures by the
clinicians to assess how the scribes
are able to help the clinician be
more quick about completing documents
and this is really
concerning because what we've found is
it's highly it's highly correlated to
how satisfied the provider was with
their scribe
and so the literature kind of leaves us
with this question
of do medical scribes
affect the amount of time it takes to
complete
documentation and how much do they
affect clinicians
and so you might not be completely
familiar with the ins and outs of
medical scribe use but i think it's
really
um we can all appreciate the importance
of having our medical records be
accurate
and completed in a timely manner and
if documentation is delayed for too long
it can be really challenging
for recall and to get the information
that belongs in the record
so some of the questions that have come
up while we
have been looking at this is what does
ordinary documentation completion time
look like for clinicians
and then subsequently how does the
clinician's time to complete
documentation
change when they're working with a
medical scribe and
those two things are are really what
we centered this project around and so
what we proposed to do this project was
describe
documentation completion time across our
organization
and then that would help us better
understand what's going on
in the general context and then applying
that
to how clinicians are completing
documentation
when they work with medical scribes and
to do this we
extracted ambulatory records from our
ehr
for all clinicians who belong to clinics
that have ever used describe
and we collected five years of data from
the ehr
on about the five clinics
and then we calculated the amount of
time to complete documentation
and whether or not ascribe was present
and then
we were able to get a general idea for
the pattern of documentation completion
in providers without scribes and then
test
a hypothesis that the use of scribes do
in fact improve documentation time
and so i'm going to give you some more
information in this project
so before we get into it all it's
helpful
to understand some of the impacts of the
ehr
and so i'm going to start there and then
for those of you who don't have a
clinical environment or
experience in the clinical environment
i'm hoping that this
part of my talk will just kind of help
you understand how the electronic health
record
is associated with clinician burnout
i will then talk about how organizations
have utilized medical scribes
to combat combat burnout and pinpoint
where the current literature falls short
in evaluating scribe use
once we understand the
kind of background and setting for this
research project
um i'll present the project i've been
working on with dr
jeff gold's research group and discuss
how this
project like adds to it and extends
um to help solve the gap in the
literature
around documentation completion time
prescribed users
so the incentivized adoption of
electronic health records was driven
primarily by the idea that ehrs would
not only improve the quality of care but
also the efficiency
of the medical system and today
over 95 of hospitals and 86
of office based physicians have adopted
some form of an ehr
and despite their promise they have
had some unintended consequences that
have unfolded from their implementation
the computer plays a really large role
in the
patient clinician relationship today and
in
their 2012 essay elizabeth tolle
described some aspects of this and
included this drawing
which is which is sorry which was
drawn by the artist who's the
seven-year-old girl
you can see sitting here on the exam
table
she gave this drawing to her doctor at
the visit
and you can see her family is also
sitting with her
they're at her visit almost unmistakably
the clinician is got his back to
her and her family because he's on the
computer
having to type or document or use ehr
reviewing a patient's medical record is
a major
early component of a clinician's
workflow in the ehr
in an ideal scenario a few days before
or the morning of a visit the clinician
has the opportunity
to review the patient's record
the second major component of the
clinician's ehr workflow
is at the point during which
second is that the point during which
the patient exam and assessment needs to
be documented
during the visit finally
the clinician must also document the
care decisions as well as the diagnostic
strategies and treatments
once the visit has ended and to do this
the
patient sometimes needs to go through
additional testing and that those test
results need to be followed up
before the clinician can close the
documentation
if the clinician falls behind on
completing documentation
it can be difficult to find the time to
go back
and complete it and ohsu
has a policy that states that encounters
that are closed after 14 days are
considered late and those encounters
that are closed after 28 days
are considered delinquent i can barely
remember what i had for dinner two weeks
ago
let alone what i had for lunch 28 days
ago
and i'm one person i don't
know how i would remember 25 to 20
to 30 people
over a period of a day or two which is
depending on your clinical schedule how
many patients you will see
and so the
memory of the patient i would assume and
of the encounter might
fade which is concerning because it'll
affect how well
the doctor or clinician can complete the
documentation
and so you can see also in this figure
that clinicians at each
time spends a significant amount of time
on the computer
and if you can guess that
isn't why they went into medicine and so
the excessive data entry requirements
and unnecessarily long notes
that have been designed towards more
billing purposes rather than patient
care
have been really strongly linked to
burnout
and this is really not surprising
considering clinicians spend more than
half their day
in the ehr recently overhauge
al did a study that found clinicians are
spending about 16 minutes
using the ehr for every patient they see
and
that is striking when you consider that
the average length of a visit to see a
patient is
only 15 minutes so they spend more time
in the chart than they do seeing the
patient
so what are we doing about it our like
solutions
research to combat
burnout the us department of health and
human services recently issued
a report that aimed at shifting the
focus for clinicians
from the administrative requirements
back to patient care
the report outlines three main goals one
to reduce clinician time and effort
required to enter information into the
ehr
two reduce the time and effort needed to
meet the regulatory components
and requirements and then three improve
the functionality and ease of use
of ehrs one way that organizations are
addressing the first goal
in this report which is reducing
recording efforts is by involving
additional healthcare team
members to assist clinicians with
certain aspects
of documentation so
the main duty of the medical scribe
is to listen to
patient clinician interactions and
capture the relevant information
that needs to be documented in the
patient's record
and often the encounter
after the encounter occurs the clinician
and the scribe will also work together
to make sure that the documentation is
comprehensive
most medical scribes receive some formal
training
to develop a basic knowledge of the
clinical practice and the scribing
process
some scribes but not all of them are
directly employed
by their organization and others
will work with a or will contract with
scribing company
who will then contract with an
organization to supply scribes
to the providers who want them several
studies have shown that medical scribes
could contribute to higher patient
volumes
increased revenue and higher patient and
provider satisfaction
and as a result the workforce of medical
scribes has grown substantially over the
past few years
medical scribes share
much of the burden associated with
documentation in the ehr
and the idea behind using them is to
relieve that documentation overload
that's pulling clinicians away from
their patient care activities
notice the difference in this picture
here
and the drawing i first showed you where
the
clinician was unable to face the child
or her family because they were not
because they were utilizing the computer
in this image that we have
with the scribe the doctor is directly
interacting with the patient and the
family
the extra person improves the clinician
patient relationship
because the clinician is able to provide
their full attention and isn't
distracted by the computer
and then scribes are also involved in a
number of other activities beyond
describing the exam room
so it's helpful for us to kind of like
understand how the scribe
gets involved in the clinician workload
so
we're going to take a look at the
workflow that we looked at without
ascribe
and see where the spread kind of fits
into that
so scribes are often asked to conduct
pre-charting
so they reduce the amount of time the
clinician spends up front
in the ehr before the visit the scribe
also allows
the clinician to spend more time with
their patient
during the exam our visit and
prevents the loss of data because
describes capturing in real time
once the patient leaves the scribe can
edit the final version of the note
and forward it along to the physician
the clinician will add details that are
important that describe
who is unlicensed is not able to
document
for example medical decision making and
then
the clinician is able to close the
documentation
and had only interacted with the ehr
theoretically a minimal amount of time
towards the end of documentation
completion
this is a streamlined way to manage the
time effort that's required
to record information in the ehr and
complete documentation
and
studies suggest that this is
well received by clinicians however
the previous findings on how scribes
impact documentation remains unclear
there are existing reports that suggest
the amount of time with scra when you
have a scribe
the amount of time to complete
documentation decreases
but there are other studies that say or
that find that there are no changes
and then as i mentioned earlier there
are other studies that use these
provider self-report measures
to report improvements in documentation
completion time
and predictably most of those reports
there was a really strong association
between
provider satisfaction and the change in
documentation completion
and so today there are only a few
authors that have actually
looked at documentation completion time
for scribe users and they're smaller
samples
with a limited number of providers
or a limited number of specialties and
so
like this is specifically noteworthy i
guess because
if the medical scribes are purported to
improve the clinician's workflow
and decrease their clerical burden we
would expect that when you use the
scribe
there should be across studies
consistent
indications that they improve
documentation timeliness and that's just
not the case
um so the real question that still is
unanswered
is when clinicians work with a medical
scribe do they complete
their documentation in a more timely
manner
i.e not getting as many late
or delinquent documentation closures
and so that kind of brings us to the aim
of this project
sorry the name of this project which is
to characterize documentation completion
time
among attending physicians in the
absence of a medical
scribe across a variety of clinical
settings
for this study we defined documentation
completion time
as the difference between the time the
provider closed the encounter and the
time at which the patient was scheduled
for a visit
and then the second aim of the study was
to quantify the changes in documentation
completion time
for physicians before and while they
were using
a medical script asking these questions
to address these aims
so now you have a broader understanding
of
the impacts of the electronic health
record and how we're using scribes to
kind of overcome clinician burden
um and so now i'm going to talk about my
study and our work
that we're doing with medical describes
in this project
so the ohsu scribe program started in
2015
to support both attending physicians and
advanced practice providers
the program has been extremely
successful the stats you see on the
slide here
are from about two years ago in 2018.
to date they have employed over 100
scribes over
in across over 85 different clinics
throughout ohsu and the program has only
continued to grow since these numbers
were captured
this provided us a really unique
opportunity to address the aims of this
project
especially considering that our research
group had an existing relationship with
the scribe program
the first goal of this project was to
characterize documentation completion
time for ambulatory encounters
across the outpatient clinics
that utilize that had previously
utilized medical scribes
and we used a retrospective
observational design
to evaluate documentation completion
time
by clinicians in specifically the
outpatient clinics
that had implemented scribes at some
point
during the time in which scribes became
available at ohsu
and we looked at how documentation
completion time
varied across medical specialty across
clinicians and then also across
or across clinics and then across
attending physicians
within clinics with more than one
provider who use describe
the second goal of this project was to
quantify
the changes in documentation completion
for clinicians who use medical scribes
and so to do this we applied a
non-randomized
controlled before after study
design study design
c hello
i think we lost sarah
yeah her um her wi-fi went out
hmm that's the poor connection
symbol on her um
yes yeah okay well maybe we can give her
a minute or so to get back connected
okay
oh there she is hi sarah
hello hi sarah
hi i'm not sure what happened but i'm
gonna just stick in on my phone
okay mark is my
computer so i'm just gonna keep this
audio going so we have it
um is that okay
yeah yeah that's fine hope maybe if it
comes back you can try going back to
video
yeah okay um so
the data collection process for this
project has been really complex and
i have a couple of figures here that uh
oh my slides might not work
if you email your slides to lynn she can
she can show for you
okay yes thank you
okay
okay
all right okay i'm just uh locating the
file on my computer and pasting
i am worried that my laptop will not be
able to send a file
um you know what it's on box
so i will forward you a link to the file
on box
because don't do that from my phone man
okay
hey sarah your video is back ah
i'm back okay okay let's try again
i'm sitting here on my phone trying to
get it
rolling okay there it goes
okay so
the process of collecting the data is
really complex and i'm going to zip
through this part so that i have time to
get to the rest
of my presentation but essentially the
data is collected in a clinical context
which means that um it's not originally
designed for research purposes
and the way we store healthcare data to
make sure that
the healthcare providers can access it
is in a specific
database that is only for essentially
healthcare services
and then we make a copy of that data
and that is how researchers are able to
access the data without slowing down
the original data space that the
organization is using for
servicing patients and we had
an epic analyst write a
an extraction code to extract
the outpatient clinic records
that are specific to this study so we
um were able to identify these clinics
that had medical scribes previously
and so we pulled all of their ambulatory
encounter records
from a year before the scribe program
started
and we extracted all of the
characteristics on those ambulatory
encounters
and we determined whether or not a
scribe was present
for those encounters using a historical
data set that was
provided by the scribe program and
essentially used those two kind of
sources
to create our final sample this is
the process of transferring the data
from the healthcare data set to
a second copy that is easier to access
for researchers
and the data transfer process is
extremely messy
and so you have to be really careful
when you go and you try and take out
data from clarity
that the values you're using and the
things that you're
trying to study are actually being
represented by the variables you're
using
from this data that's that's that's the
short part of it
and so
for these clinics we extracted records
starting in january 1st
of 2014 through december 31st of 2019
and for each clinic we extracted a bunch
of characteristics
about the the clinic or the encounter
excuse me in the including the provider
who documented the encounter whether or
not a scribe was present
the start time of the visit
the time that the provider completed the
documentation
and some other uh descriptive
characteristics such as the complexity
of the case
of the of the bill essentially the
billing code for the visit
and in our final sample we included
office visits procedure visits and pre
prenatal visits um because these were
the most applicable ambulatory
encounter types that we could include
for this analysis
we intended to measure the difference in
the
start time and the completion time and
to do that we made sure to exclude
encounters
that didn't that hadn't been yet closed
so they didn't have a completion time
and then because workflow differences
are
because workflows may differ on the
weekend we excluded
encounters that occurred on a saturday
or sunday because
there were there were some and
the ohsu scribe program also services
not just physicians but advanced
practice providers and so
we we limited our analysis to only
attending physicians
because the practices of documentation
might be different depending on your
background and training
and then to minimize any bias that might
result from the
clinician not regularly working with
patients we made sure to only include
a physician if they had at least 100
encounters
for each year of the study period that
they were included
and finally with aim2 where we're
looking at the pre
and post describe use
differences we only included scribe
provider pairs that had at least 100
encounters to account for
adjusting to the relationship and
just the amount of time they spent
together as a dyad
for aim 1 the average length and
variance in
time to complete encounters was found
and we
looked at it across medical specialties
clinics and across clinicians
and compared clinicians within clinics
who are sorry we compared clinicians
in clinics that had more than one
provider
the this allowed us to kind of
understand how documentation is
completed in general without
the presence of a scribe and then for
aim2
we analyzed physicians who had
encounters
with and without scribes and found the
differences in time to complete
documentation
and for each physician
uh we compare so sorry for we found that
for each physician we found
the differences in time to complete and
counter documentation
we compared before and after scribe and
then we were able to
control with uh peers in the same clinic
at the same time
who did not work with the scribe to try
and account for some of the temporal
things that are going on that might have
affected documentation
in general so
the study isn't without limitations some
of the
major limitations of the project are
that it's retrospective in nature so our
data collection
it has an inferior level of evidence
compared to prospective studies
it also means that our analysis is at
risk of being biased
um the project only includes data from a
single institution
which is another limitation it limits
the generalizability of our findings so
something that's occurring at ohsu might
only be occurring because it's ohsu not
because of the scribes and so uh
further work needs to assess this kind
of
uh document the kinds of things we find
need to be assessed at other
institutions as well
and then finally the physician
interaction with the ehr and
documentation hygiene
is a in general a really really complex
issue and
this project only measures uh really a
small sliver of the relationship between
scribes and providers
and so future work really needs to
develop a more comprehensive model
that evaluates the impacts of scribes on
documentation hygiene in a way that
captures the complexity of the
relationship in a better way than just a
single variable does
so today is my proposal defense
and if i pass i will go on
to well we've already completed the data
extraction for this project and i did
an initial data extraction at the
beginning of the year
and i cleaned verified and analyzed that
data so the analysis
files are actually already completed for
this project too
our analyst emailed me on sunday night
that all of the data for this project is
available and so
i'm really excited to to put my data
gloves on and get started i really
enjoy that part of this um
but um first i needed to hear
from colleagues and get some feedback
about how we're approaching this project
and so
my after this defense i will
proceed to analyze the rest of my data
i'm hoping to have that completed by
march
and then i'm hoping to have a draft
that is workable by beginning
of april and then defend at the end of
may
um and the defense date and time is
already set so
if you would like an invite and you
haven't received one i'm happy to send
it to you
this is a literature that i talked about
in
my slides and i can send that to you if
you would
like a copy of that before i close the
presentation i just want to take a
moment
to recognize some important people who
have been involved in making this work
possible
uh dr weiskopf and dr mohan and dr gold
thank you for teaching me and supporting
me as a researcher and trainee
i have so much to learn from you guys um
but you are
you've all made a world of a difference
in being able to
carry out this project sky thank you so
much
for all the afternoons you've listened
to me ramble about my project
and for sharing your advice on like
fitting all the pieces together and
um just managing it i could not have
gotten this far without you
and then finally i want to thank
the sky program manager uh james bechten
and i think he's here and others who
have
are involved in this project who i
couldn't find pictures for
or um otherwise maybe you wouldn't have
fit
um so
here we are it's 20 21 it's almost a
decade actually since toll published
this article
and um health professionals are still
required to divide their attention
pretty heavily between patients and the
ehr
many believe that this is compromising
the patient physician relationship
and most clinicians are still spending
more than half of their professional
time
typing and clicking and checking boxes
in the ehr
demanding documentation related
activities continue to be the leading
cause of job dissatisfaction in the
healthcare fields
and the rates the high rates of burnout
are extremely concerning
the use of medical scribes may
liberate clinicians from much of this
unnecessary busy work
but it remains unclear if the
documentation completion time
of notes documented by scribes is
actually any different than when
the clinician is working on their own so
the goal of this research project really
is to just help us better understand
the relationship between scribe use and
documentation completion time
because at the end of the day we should
be using tools
and designing interventions that
are able to ultimately
provide better
experiences to providers and
that leads to improving outcomes and
patient experiences which
both deserve better so yeah
thank you guys for all coming today and
i
am excited to take some questions and
have some comments
or any suggestions on this project
great thank you sarah um
i have a question excellent that then
we'll um
have a couple kind of general comments
but um
i apologize if i missed this um are you
um planning to and and you may not have
enough
data to do this but um to look at
different specialties because
it may well be that certain um physician
specialties by the nature of the work
they do
might get more advantage from scribes
than others
this is it's something i'm really
excited to look at so we also did a
preliminary analysis
of only scribe documented encounters
and what we have found is that um
there is a huge variation
in documentation completion um
and that initially we thought that it
would be
and this is just inscribed encounters so
we haven't yet looked at
clinicians who don't work with scribes
but in that analysis what we did find
was that the variation
is occurring at the provider level not
necessarily just the specialty level
and so the other really complex thing
about this whole project that i really
didn't have time to get into
is it's a multi-level
um just there's so many factors that
play into it on a multi-level
in the multi-level system that makes it
yeah so so to answer your question yes
we're going to definitely be looking at
specialties and documentation closure
variation and specialties
yeah that's great the um the the general
comments i don't want to take all your
time because i know there's probably
other questions but um
um david bates many of you know david
bates or know of david bates has said
in in public um i mean scribes are here
to stay and
your work is very important um but you
know that scribes also kind of represent
a failure
of our ehr systems because they are so
hard to get
data into that said um
many of you some of you may have heard
of initiate an initiative that's uh
going on
funded by the national library of
medicine a number of
institutions are involved colombia
vanderbilt
called 25 by five which aims to
reduce the burden of documentation to 25
of which scribes may be uh part of
that process um one i've invited one of
the principals to speak
and um um sarah
uh rosetti from columbia
uh will be presenting to our conference
on on may 13th
about a week before your defense so uh
people
may want to keep that in mind but
anyways i don't want to take all your
question time
i'm happy to open up the floor either
type into the chat box or
unmute your microphone to ask
any questions you have
hey sarah great work thank you thank you
um i have a couple questions
um about your methods i'm interested
can you tell us a little more about why
you decided to leave out advanced
uh advanced practice um providers
because it seems to me that
one of your your questions pretty
general like
is this worth it and and how much does
describes improve this so i would think
that the your
you would your answers would be best
termed in
in terms of uh what a whole organization
might
invest in which could include advanced
practice providers that's a really good
question
um are the sample size
of advanced practice providers that have
worked with the scribes
with the ohsu scribe program is really
small and so
it would make it really difficult to be
able to look at how it's actually
impacting
across the different uh advanced
practice providers which is really
unfortunate
because as i i know joan will attest to
like this is one of the biggest places
where scribes haven't really been
researched is looking at
how advanced practice providers are
working with scribes and it's really
needed because they are working with
them
throughout all sorts of organizations
and
it's definitely a limitation of this
work and i wish we had a more
advanced practice providers who are
using scribes because then we'd be able
to answer that
and and i had two other methods
questions
one why not well do you think about
controlling for fte or or sort of
overall
clinical burden of the providers because
it may be that providers who have less
clinical load even if they
have other duties might
really have might apportion their time
very differently
than providers who have a you know a
full full week of
clinic every week that's number one and
then the last question i have is
does would it seems
that it might not be too difficult to
include a
some kind of proxy for quality or payoff
in this analysis uh for example
just something as simple as coding level
right did you
it was it you know the coding complexity
the 99213 for us in pediatrics or two on
four or five
in which case you could uh sort of you
know begin
to suggest if there is um a trade-off or
or something along those lines of of
productivity or revenue
those are both really good questions too
um
they're really i think dr weiskopf and i
were talking about this yesterday but
one of the really unique
like aspects of this project is i'm
working with like
metadata about healthcare because we're
look we're not looking at like
blood pressure or cbc's
in the records of patients i'm looking
at the information about
encounters and so it's been really
difficult to capture
and find the right values to measure
the kinds of things we want to look at
and so
i don't quite know how we would go about
capturing
fte um
[Music]
but i think that using it could be
valuable
in being able to control and how much
the provider is working clinically i
think that's a really important factor
and i would hope that by using just the
number of encounters the provider has
and kind of controlling on that helps
because that's looking at their volume
of patients
um but i think you're right um fte
would might be a helpful variable too
in like a complementing that like
number of encounters um the quality
quality we have so we have cpt codes
and i will be able to hopefully control
our analysis
on the level of complexity but um
i just haven't gotten to that point
quite yet
trying to design these models the
biggest uh
the biggest challenge with this project
so far has been
getting the data cleaned and prepped for
analysis
um we don't talk about it enough but
that's like
90 percent not really it's more like
probably like 70 but it's so much
time to like get it all together
put it all in the right format and then
really design
your analysis in a way that critically
thinks about
how you want to model what you're asking
and so i've jumped around between models
and
trying to consider which type of model
to use for this analysis
um and so i'm just not quite yet
there to like the controlling for
confounders yet i guess
if that makes any sense
clearly you thought about it thanks so
much yeah
thank you
great there there is a comment in the
chat box from vishnu
yeah yeah just i just wanted to say that
you know calculating fte
for clinicians and academic medical
centers it's often challenging
in community organizations they
typically 100 clinical monday through
friday
um but in in academic institutions ft's
are often variable there are competing
uh interests like research and teaching
and and the pool of clinical fd often
kind of expands and shrinks depending on
their other interests also so it becomes
a little bit more challenging
the other the other thing is and it's
jeff here
jeff gold is um one of the advantages to
what
sarah's data set is is that she has
a wide breadth of clinics that she's
looking at and these are include
specialty clinics right so it's not just
primary care and so when you look at
certain things
like whether it's even geriatrics uh
cardiology
a lot of these services their clinical
fte is actually split
between ambulatory and inpatient so as
well it becomes a lot more difficult
because it's not just a pure
and it's not just that the only way that
they could work would be with a scribe
a large amount of their fte may be
scribe independent because of that
workflow is different
and while you were saying that dr gold i
realized
that one of the things i didn't add to
my presentation was just like the
sheer size of this data um i have
millions and millions of encounters so
the 2014 data that we pulled which was
without scribes was
about 900 and something encounters and
ohsu's total number of encounters each
year increases
and so the the end each
year of my sample just increases um
and so i have a very large data set
and i think that's another strength to
this study is that we do
have um a large sample size
good any other questions out there
well if not um thank you again sarah for
your
interesting presentation and we will
look forward to
um hearing your results in may
okay so have a good day everyone bye-bye